human Minds evolved in a planetary
ecosystem and therefore we evolved to be
very reactive and so you could say human
Minds which have developed higher level
mental functions and are reactive to
their environment they're difficult to
predict but although even human Minds
can be predicted and psychology is
making progress in that direction but a
mind without higher level mental
functions can behave according to
precise regularities why can't right
that's what I want to understand why why
are there these reg regularities or or
laws or or consistencies in so you say
that you know our mind um uh it works in
particular ways why does it produce the
appearance of a brain and neurons and
all of that kind of stuff